hi
thank you good
good evening and welcome to this
district planning committee meeting
on thursday the 8th of october 2020
my name is councillor penny chenna and
i'm the vice chairman of this committee
this means meeting is held under new
regulations
which came into effect on the fourth of
april in response to kobe 19 situation
there are just good evening and welcome
to this district planning committee
meeting
on thursday
to ensure your microphone remains muted
and your video feed
off when not addressing the committee
this will reduce the background noises
and avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent
to being recorded members and officers
during each item please use the chat
function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be
used please for any other purpose please
do not use the raise hand function as
this is
on available sorry please don't use the
raise hand function as this is not
available
on all member devices go into the agenda
papers
please ensure you reference a page or
paragraph number
and lastly if members need to leave the
meeting at any point
please do make this known and use the
chant function to signify that you do
need to leave the meeting now
if i may ask officers taking part in the
meeting to introduce themselves
starting with please i will start with
mr lee first if i may
mr lee please thank you chairman
i am matthew lee lead specialist place
and chief plan officer here at morgan
district council
thank you thank you very much ms
matthews
good evening chairman good evening
members and i'm catherine matthews
specialist in development management
um i did have mr crouch on my list but i
believe that mr quelch may not be
attending tonight please can you advise
please miss bird
um yes chairman i can advise he isn't in
attendance tonight
okay thank you very much um and miss
bird
introduce yourself please good evening
members good evening chairman
i'm tara bird i'm the committee services
officer for tonight thank you
and can i please ask are there any other
officers present is
michael johnson here with us tonight or
not
yes chairman i'm here ah if you could
introduce yourself please michael
my name is michael johnson i'm a lead
specialist development management
thank you i was hoping you were here
because i i couldn't see you across the
front actually i thought
okay i've been a while counsellor thank
you oh thank you very much
okay that's lovely so there's no other
officers is there present that i haven't
actually referred to
if so please do identify yourselves now
be very grateful
okay thank you very much tara in that
case then please can we move on
and can i ask you now please to carry
out a roll call
of members to confirm who is in
attendance thank you very much indeed
yes chairman of course uh members if you
can just advise if you're in attendance
when i call your name please
starting with councillor bamford
i'm here tara thank you very much
councillor bassinger
good evening everyone i'm present thank
you
councillor miss beale present
thank you councillor brian bill good
evening everyone
i'm present
hi present good evening everyone good
evening
uh councillor edwards good evening i'm
present
cancer mrs fleming present tara
good evening tara members i'm present
good evening
councillor helm present tara
thank you councillor hole
good evening everybody i'm present much
councillor jarvis
what do you mean good evening thank you
councillor keys
now counselor keys cancer lagging
cancer legend
jeremy doesn't he is here i believe
um i i can't see hit him to be honest
but um
you've probably got more uh more
visibility than myself
during the meeting yes i have got the
council i can join the meeting
just popped up yep council lagging are
you there
right he might be on mute i wonder if
he's on mute he's on youtube
you might be on mute
right right okay okay a cat's a maze
uh present tara good evening good
evening thank you very much
casler morley um sorry this is maddie
thompson um he's had to give his
apologies please he's had to work late
so
um i'll mention it now and then again
later thank you thank you very much
councillor morris good evening and
welcome
good evening thank you very much
councillor nunn
uh yes here tara thank you thank you
very much
councillor shortnessy good evening
evening everyone
good evening thank you very that was
very faint councillors
shawna see
did you catch it tara i am here thank
you okay
thank you very much yes i've got that
councillor
good evening tara good evening chairman
i am present
thank you very much good evening good
evening councillor stamp
um good evening to our remembers um
council langham said his line keeps
dropping out but i think he's actually
put on chat that he's actually here
now yes thank you very much
uh castle stilts good evening everybody
i'm
present thank you very much councillor
swain
um yes i'm here uh tara um i'm afraid i
seem to have lost
the chat function so i may have to raise
a hand at some point
okay thank you very much we'll keep an
eye out for that uh councillor mrs
thompson
um i'm here thank you thank you and
councillor miss white
president tara thank you very much thank
you chairman that's the role cooldown
thank you very much tara now then if i
could please move on um to a gender item
number three oh no bobby number two
sorry apologies for absence may have
apologies for absence please tara
uh yes chairman apologies have been
received from uh councillor boyce
councillor direct council durham cancer
morley and cancer schemes
thank you very much indeed thank you
yeah we will sorry
did you say something sorry no just say
thank you oh oh okay thanks very much
can we now move on then please for
gender item number three
and this is the minutes of the 13th of
august 2020.
um it is um which is recommended held on
the third
on the 30th of august found on pages 5
to 18
are approved as a true and accurate
record i so
move that but if you wish to set the
motion please can you turn on your video
un mute your microphone and state your
name now
i'd be very grateful thank you okay
thank you um can we take then
those minutes are a true and accurate
record
can i do that by a sentence agreed
i agree agreed there's no dissension
three
three very much in that then so
therefore those
minutes are agreed if i could then move
on
um to agenda item number four we've now
got the minutes of the 20th of august
and therefore um these were the minutes
of the special meal meeting held on
the 20th of august 2020 members and they
are found on pages
19 to 44 and obviously we need to prove
those as a true and accurate record iso
move
and if you wish to second that motion
please can i ask you to turn on your
video
i'm mute your name now
happy to second that there was a there
was a number there a number of voices
came in
so it's definitely been seconded again
can i please ask if there's no matter of
accuracy we agree those minutes
thank you can we do that by ascent
agreed
no one's going against that thank you
very much tara we can say those
then are agreed by ascent
thank you very much indeed we're now
going to move on to declaration of
interest
i will read out the full statement for
you
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to men to items of business on
the agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members you're also reminded that you
are also required to disclose any such
interests
as soon as you become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
and if any member has an interested to
care please can i ask now you to use the
chat function now to indicate
and i will invite you to speak um i
cannot see anyone wishing to declare
so i will therefore declare myself i
will declare my interest which is
non-pecuniary
that i'm also a member of essex county
council
and will have been concerned consulted
as with other applications
on any matter under its remit such as
highways
um access possibly uh flooding they're
also the
local lead flood authority so any matter
that it would have been consulted on
so i'm just checking i can't see tara
anyone wishing to declare
is that correct have you got anything
different to me that's correct chip and
i haven't got anyone asking to declare
okay thank you very much in that case
members we can move swiftly on to agenda
item number six
and this is um application twenty slash
zero zero eight four six slash reserved
art which is res land north west of two
malden road
burnham on crouch and um
it's found on pages members 45 to 84.
now in the moment i will call on the
officer um to present this item
and members again i i know i keep
repeating myself but i hope it is
helpful
that if should you wish to speak on this
item please make this known by using the
chat function within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn and
please can ask you to keep your points
um clear and and concise and i will
advise at the point that i open
um the debate to members so i will make
that clear um so we can go forward on
that
therefore um miss matthews um
i believe that you are going to present
this report i'd be grateful then if i
could call on you now
to do that thank you very much indeed
thank you chairman just going to um
i believe we're going to share on screen
are you miss matthews thank you
can we check all members can see that
please the screen sharing
yes thank you no one's got a problem yes
thank you
bye thank you thank you thank you ms
matthews if you could proceed i'd be
very grateful thank you
you okay um yeah
just trying to get my notes and the
screen up at the same time
i know it's can be tricky
all right i thought i was wrong
don't worry just if it needs a bit of
what penny that is san here
councillor hull hello can i put a number
in your interest
hello can i put a non-pecunial interest
in in this
in the site i don't know if it's
relevant or not but yes if you want to
declare declare now yes
okay because we're waiting for miss
matthews to get her notes and everything
up yes
david my partner david shaw actually
worked for john wilson that originally
sold the land to the people i don't know
if that makes a difference or not
okay so you're declaring number two okay
did you get at that yes
thank you very much yes i've got that
thank you miss bird thank you all right
are you all right there um
thank you right okay right so okay
proceed
thank you okay so um
so this is a reserved matters
application for the approval of parents
scale and landscaping following um an
outline plan permission
and for 103 bungalows
care home assisted living apartments
including affordable housing community
centre shops
[Music]
medical center offices maintenance
buildings and associated
uh works so first of all i'd like to
draw members attention to the members
update where there's
um suggest um recommended revision to
the landscape straight planting plans
referred to in their conditions there's
also consultation responses from the
tree consultant
and essex county council adult adult
social care
there's one further verbal update that i
need to give to members and that is that
the description
um on the agenda is uh incorrect and
they should have also referred to
um scale as one of the reserve matters
that is
um forms part of the current application
so this first slide um
shows where the application site is and
as
i said before the app site and the
application site benefits from outline
plan permission
with the matters of access and layout
approved
and condition one of the outline plan
permission requires that matters of
appearance
landscaping scale address the reserve
matters application which is the subject
of this current application
this application is a resubmission
following the refusal of a previous
application for the same description of
development
that application was refused for a
single reason relating to the design of
the proposed buildings
the main concern raised related to the
contemporary and flat roof design the
majority of the buildings
posed in the context of the site
surroundings and the design
the design and external appearance of
the building to subject the current
application
are more traditional and include pitched
rather than flat roofs
facing brickwork and where the boarding
is proposed rather than some of the more
contemporary
materials previously proposed and
but there are some still some
contemporary detailing of the buildings
um the site is approximately 15.7
hectares in size
located to the north of malden road east
of tinker's hole
um and west of bernamon craft settlement
boundary the site is currently a field
with a public footpath
along the eastern boundary
um this burnham reservoir is cited
immediately adjacent to the west of the
site
and while elm farm and elmwood
question center is is to the southwest
the dwellings are in the
linear layout along malden road to the
east
and this slide shows that and the
proposed layout of the site
you've got bungalows sited within the
northern southern and western areas of
the site
you've got a central hub where there
will be uh well located this whole
center eastern side of the site and will
contain two-story medical center
two-story um 70-bed care home 55
independent living flats a parade of
shops including a1 a3 and a5 ucs with
apartments at first floor
and a parked single part two-story
community hub center
containing indoor and outdoor sports and
social facilities
the site offices and maintenance
buildings are located in the southern
part of the site
in terms of access this was approved at
the outlying stage
and that would be off molden road on the
south side of the application sites
there'd be a secondary access for
emergencies pedestrians and cyclists on
the western side
of tinker's hole and within the site
they'll be there the main road running
in a north-south direction
with 10 quadricep roads for residential
um
residential clusters there would be a
footpath stroke cycleway
stroke exercise trail around the outside
of the development
and which in places would accommodate
for mrs bridalway
details the bridal way to be submitted
um at a later date as required by the
section 106
agreement
so this is um another proposed layout
and we've got a landscape master plan um
in terms of landscape maintenance and
management the the provisions are within
the 106 agreement
um and this is to include um sustainable
urban drainage system
and also a lake as you can see in the
northeast corner there'll be a local
equipped area of play to the west of the
community center hub i'll hover over
that there the leap
um with exact details again to be agreed
um in accordance with the 106 agreement
and
as as mentioned in the members update
the tree consultant has no objections to
the proposal
um but there is an additional condition
um recommended
following his comments on the details
that have been submitted
so moving on to the house types we've
got the
bungalows and there'll be a total of
five bungalow types
and then a mix of one two and three
bedrooms um each bungalow would have two
parking spaces plus um visitor parking
which complies with the adopted
standards
and cycle parking will be provided um
although further details are recommended
to be required by condition
so this is bungalow type one i'll just
um go through these
they're all fairly similar appearance
[Music]
we've got some illustrations of the
bungalows and
then just for members information um
these are um the illustrations of the
previous proposals which was refused
and and as part of this application the
number the number of types of bungalows
have been reduced from 15 to
only five and they include pitched
rather than
any element of flat roofs as previously
the case
against more previously refused
so moving on to the independent living
units
and there'll be 55 independent living
room units 50
50 of which would be affordable housing
um
as required and secured through the 106
agreement there'll be a mix of one and
two bed units in three
blocks within the eastern part of the
site and then include a community
communal facilities and 54 parking
spaces which is sufficient
um yes so
these are the layouts and i also
included on this
um an example of the the landscaping
proposed
and on the right hand side you've got
the um
existing bridal way which would be
retained and
within the hedge within hedging and
trees there
you also got the the lake um next to the
independent um living units
[Music]
and so these are the floor plans
obviously quite small scale but
there's a general idea and then this
block um one of the blocks here would be
including the um some of the communal
facilities
so these are the end in elevations
for the three blocks and you can see the
glazed walkways that will be linking the
blocks
together again some more elevations
illustrations and again
the previously refused elevations
for the independent living units
so the care home um
[Music]
shown on these slides so that's the um
the layout there
and the elevations
the care home would have 55 58 sorry
vehicle parking spaces which
um considered to be sufficient provision
we've got illustrations there
and again um elevations are previously
refused care home
scheme details um
so you can see sorry going back um
this in terms of the changes we've also
got a um
visual focal point in terms of a clock
tower that's been added which wasn't
part the previous
application and it would be a two bay
two story open bay let's say you get
with a
turret and a clock incorporated
the community center and community hub
would be 35
parking spaces and which is considered
sufficient particularly given that
people can walk and cycle to the hub
from those living on site so these are
the elevations
proposed
the uh yeah and some floor plans and
rooflands
there'll be a partly to partly to story
as i mentioned earlier
some illustrations and again
what was then previously proposed and
previously refused
so so now it's more of traditional
design including pictures
and articulation so the building appears
as a
series of connected buildings and the um
the boat building
um shed type roof is referenced
referencing the boat building um sail
lofts within
within the district
medical center and we've got floor plans
and roof plans there
will be 15 vehicle parking spaces
proposed as part of that
elevations illustration
and again the previously refused
proposed scheme
is now designed as what described as an
evolved barn finishing weatherboarding
and facing brickwork with pitch roofs
so we've got mixed use here we've got
shops um
first floor um ground floor sorry and um
flats at first floor and second floor
within the
second floor being within the roof space
and
this this remains unchanged from the
previous application
and 18 parking spaces proposed
3d drawings
and the final thing is the offices and
maintenance buildings
um which you've got the floor plans
there for the maintenance building
[Music]
security office floor plans and
elevations
these all remain unchanged from the
previous application
25 parking spaces and for the offices
and maintenance buildings
but then they've got some site photos
today's members aren't familiar with the
site
put the dwelling adjacent to the
application site
elm farm house and a street scene
um east of the site
um pictures of the field that
currently uh is the application site
some more illustrations
okay so in conclusion um the principal
development proposed
is um including its impact on
infrastructure or services
it's already been accepted with the
outline plan permission and
um provisions are made within the
section 106 agreement
to secure any deficiencies that were
identified
and the previous reserve matters
application was only refused
for concerns relating to design the
proposed buildings
and it would be also unreasonable for
other concerns to
be raised the housing makes a cause with
that approved at the outline stage
proposal complies with the parameters
set out at the outline stage
such as story heights and floor space
limits that were imposed and the
conditions attached to the outline plan
permission require detailed surface
water and foul drainage scheme to be
submitted
and those which cover and also
conditions which cover the issue of
ecology and nature conservation
and bird and black boxes are proposed
and
on some of the dwellings have been taken
into account all material considerations
that are relevant
it's considered that the details of the
scale appearance and landscaping
submitted are acceptable
and would not result in deductible harm
to the carriage of the area
the development complies with the
obligations agreed through the
106 agreement and the relevant
conditions of the outline plan
permission
and an officer's view has satisfactorily
addressed the reasons why the previous
application
with the matters application was refused
thank you members
thank you very much miss matthews right
members under the council's public
participation scheme
we have received one submission in line
with the public participation scheme
i have reviews this and i will now ask
mr johnson
the lead specialist development
management to read it to the committee
allocating of course um the time allowed
in accordance with the scheme of two
minutes
so mr johnson the submissions from the
agent mr stewart
could i call on you please to read that
out for members thank you
yes thank you chair good afternoon
chairman and members
outline planning permission was granted
for this development in september 2019
with a related section 106 agreement
signed the development will help meet
important housing needs for elderly
persons in the district
that will not be addressed through the
sites allocated for new homes in the
local plan
the principle of the development the
number mix type of units including
affordable
housing was approved as part of the
outline permission
the layout of the site and the means of
access were also approved
service and file water drainage ecology
lighting
and the full range of other detailed
design mappers are required to be agreed
by planning conditions and section 106
obligations
of the outlying permission and good
progress has been made on discharging
these
this current application seeks to
council approval of reserve matters
mainly the scale and appearance of the
buildings and the hard and soft
landscaping of the site
it is a second such application the
first was refused in june 2020
solely based on the contemporary
appearance and particularly the flat
roofs
of the buildings then proposed other
matters such as hard and soft
landscaping and the scale of the
buildings
were not objected to by the council this
revised application follows three
pre-application meetings
two of which were with elected members
at which constructive and helpful
discussion was had
and which was guided and which has
guided this revised submission
the scheme presented to members today is
largely based upon that shown at the
most recent pre-application consultation
meeting
with further refinements having been
made by the scheme architect
to reflect the comments of members at
that last meeting
flat roofs have been replaced with pitch
roofs to wall buildings
and a traditional approach to design has
been used with cues taken from notable
large building forms in the district
such as the sail lofts at tullesbury and
boatsheds at burnham on crouch
materials are also now traditional in
type texturing colors
in this way the scheme is now considered
to be appropriate in design reflecting
the character and appearance of the
wider area
the applicant is pleased to see the
recommendation of approval which
reflects much hard work by council staff
elected members and the development team
the office's report is commended to the
committee
thank you chairman thank you very much
mr johnson thank you very much
and that was great in the time um can i
just ask um
did any other officer want to come in at
this stage just i know miss mathews has
presented we've heard the submission
read out with mr johnson
mr lee at this stage no nothing at this
time chairman
thank you very much indeed well then
members there the recommendation i would
like to draw to your attention
is set out within the report and is as
follows the planning application
twenty slash zero zero eight four six
slash res
land northwest of two moon enrolled
burnham and crouch be approved subject
to the conditions
in section eight of the report however
you heard ms matthews indicate and you
have received it
uh the update for members and you'll
note that there is some revision
to the um conditions i think namely and
i'm sure miss matthews will correct me
um conditions two four and five and
there's an additional recommendation
which is um number 20. so members i so
move
that recommendation if you can second
that can you please turn on your video
and um state your name please
second thank you very much indeed
um so that has now been seconded so
therefore members i'm now going to
invite any members to make any comments
on the report i have got some names
wishing to speak i can see council has
heard and councillors white
can i go to the burnham members first is
any burnham member wishing to uh
come in at this stage being effectively
ward members
chairman i'm quite happy to wait i'll
come in later thank you
okay right i i take it that's the same
counselor hull um you don't wish to say
anything at the stage i'll move on to
those that have asked to speak
or do you come in later you can always
come in later
okay hopefully thank you okay right in
that case then the first name i saw
uh asking to speak was counsellor heard
please
um thank you very much chairman um i do
note
that this application relates to the
appearance landscaping
and scale so my comments will be
confined to that a couple of questions
i'd like to ask the first thing is that
it says in the report that there is a
bus stop
115 meters from the site
and there's a cafe i think it was 110
meters from the
site uh and bearing in mind this is for
elderly people
um i see that there are there's no
footpaths
uh there so i think them walking along
a 60 mile an hour road particularly one
which is known as the burnham bins
seems to me to be quite dangerous
it's been refused because of the
contemporary design and i am encouraged
by the newer designs um but what i
haven't seen
uh and i hope i didn't miss it uh miss
matthew
ms matthews kindly put up the bungalows
that were refused
but i didn't see the bungalows that
we're actually voting upon today
and she said that they've been reduced
from 15 to 5 but i couldn't quite see
whether or not so well my question is
are there any more flat roofed
buildings there i'm very concerned
about the small patio areas
that have been allocated there doesn't
seem to be
any boundaries or fences i think that's
that's fair enough because it's a
communal
building but what i'd like to know is
why do they feel it is necessary
to have a condition to stop anyone
building any outbuildings and
is it because this design does not
give the minimum required amenity space
of 25 square meters on the
the back to back immunity space so it
says it's not considered
um to be detrimental i'd like to know
who buy please i'd also like to know
about
any solar panels that are going on there
it was mentioned
on the in the report but i couldn't
quite see
how many solar panels there should be
and i'm very concerned that of the
responses
initially um there was only
one out of nine responses
in this application there are two
on the update but that still leaves
seven people who haven't responded and
merely referred
to the previous application
um i find it very difficult
to accept uh that they are liking this
building to tullesbury some
22 miles away and and 40 minute drive
to have the sail loft i don't think
that's got very much to do
with this application i know that
burnham is known for its sailing but
i think it's a bit uh a bit rich to
um suggest that this could be likened to
to tollsby so my questions are the
footpaths
um the the lack
of um agreement for to to give
the minimum the minimum amount of space
on all of those
to those residents and when they're
asking that
it's considered not to have any harm on
the residents
who buy because if i was a resident
there
with less than the required space and
a condition to say i can't have a glass
house shed
or any kind of bunker there
i'm afraid i'm not i'd like to know the
answer to those questions please
chairman thank you
yes thank you um miss matthews i will
come to you i just would remind members
as
miss matthews pointed out um in her
presentation
um that this is
a resubmission bearing in mind the last
application and that was reviews
on one issue and the design um
of the development um and she's
explained about how meeting the 106
obligations and the previous um
uh permission given um but obviously i'm
going to come to miss matthews to answer
those points and regarding the
uh the sale offs at tullesbury i think
it the word used was within
uh what mr johnson uh read out was um
took a cue from them it wasn't saying it
was trying to reflect totally
um you know the the sale loss because
they're they're the larger buildings
um miss uh miss bird would it be
possible actually for
councillor heard um to see uh the
bungalows again or miss matthews sorry i
think it's you sharing the screen
if you could just put the bungalows up
because clean uh council heard missed
that so i'd be very grateful
and regarding um the five you referred
to um
council heard it's uh the sort of
designs there was 15 before
so it's the designs that have come down
to five i don't want to mislead anyone
thinking
there's only five it's five types i
believe so miss matthews have you just
got the bungalows there so council heard
um can see those that would be helpful
and um you or whoever to answer the
questions he has posed please
thank you
um yes so um hopefully members can see
the um
presentation again yes yeah we got on
screen yeah we've got the signs
yes okay so the um the proposed
bungalows are these they've got type one
there
which i saw yes you did put that yes yes
in type
two so no no flat ruse there's some
as i mentioned before there's some
contemporary elements so you've got
these um that's
i'd say that was a more contemporary
element but um
not nothing like um was proposed before
they've got type 3
and then the illustrations and then
these are the ones that were refused
before
so incorporating quite um big areas of
flat roof and monopitch roofs
and okay so they're the uh
bungalow types um in terms of
the bus job issue
and the footpath issue there is a
requirement
as part of the outline plan permission
that there are
bus stops provided um two per stop
provided
um either within the site or just
outside the site
and also that the the foot there is a
footpath which is um provided along the
main road to connect with the existing
footpaths
along the main road to the to the east
so i think that
um covers that point that was made um
yes the patios are freaked and bungalow
are
small and but that was part of the
um design proposal that it um it was a
communal and garden area so they have
their
small area of their own but um they
would
mainly share the communal areas and the
um and the lack of um
boundary treatment is sort of part of
the the design ethos
and of of the development and
it seemed to be a reasonable
reasonable approach um and so
so they there is a condition
recommending that permitted development
rights for
um means of enclosure are taken away and
it doesn't mean that
nobody can have means of enclosure at
any point
in the in the future that just means
that they would need to
apply and ask ask for it and then
obviously the council can consider
whether what they particularly want to
do would be
um acceptable or not and by taking the
rights away doesn't necessarily mean
that they can't
nobody can have any it's just to retain
control so that the
design and the character of the
development can be
maintained in the future and council
retains control over that
um in terms of the um
condition taking away permitted
development rights for outbuildings
council herd is correct is that the
reason for that is to make
sure that um these back-to-back
distances
are maintained um and given the more
communal nature of the development
and which which is moving away from
private i mean you just face more to a
communal
um immediate space with what i've said
before
um yeah and solar panels
sorry uh ms matthews coming on a point
there actually obviously
council heard
also members need to be aware that
permitted development only relates
in relation to outbuildings only relates
to the cartilage of a property
the shared amenity space proposed and
how that would work would
probably mean that the actual buildings
wouldn't have any
specific curse so they wouldn't actually
be any real permitted development rights
per se anyway um they might
it might actually be in the front garden
obviously he doesn't find the highway
there's lots of reasons
as matthew's explaining relation to
design etc and the impact of this whole
area while the authority or the local
plan authorities are recommending that
these conditions should be removed and
as
matthew said it doesn't mean they
couldn't apply but actually
to the rear of the properties they
probably wouldn't have been able to put
up a fence without needing planning
permission anyway
so if nothing else this is a point of
clarity would hopefully give some
clarity to the future occupiers rather
than
leading to a potential confusion in the
future thank you chairman
thank you mr matthews please continue
thank you
so the um thank you mr lee
the um in terms of the solar panels um
these uh
these are the independent living units
that are brought up here so we've got
solar panels on the roof
here um and some more on block two down
the bottom there it doesn't seem oh yes
on the
care home this is um one elevation that
includes
a number of solar panels on that
building
and again on oh no they might be uh roof
lights
and so there's there's a number of
uh of them solar panels
but um they're shown on the uh on the
elevations
um and hopefully that answers
the question about solar panels and in
terms of lack of consultation responses
there there are a lot there are a number
that haven't
um come back um but
the because the application
um hasn't been in that long
and the consultation requests were sent
out when the application was received
they've all had at least the the minimum
time that um they they are allowed
but um normally an application like this
would would have um
been in the system um for longer and and
given
consultants more of a chance to to to
come back
um but in this case because the
application was very similar
um in terms of the comments that they
would make
um there there's no um
officers aren't the view that there's
any issue with waiting for those
consultation responses because they're
very unlikely to change given the nature
of those consultees interest
or um interest in in the proposal
so that explains the consultation
responses
um and the ones we've got
the update is as as up to date as we
have in terms of
consulting replying
thank you thank you very much um now
council heard before i move on to
council right here i've noticed you have
asked if you could come back
is this a supplementary question please
yes thank you chairman uh i'm not uh i'm
not
i can't sound really satisfied about the
amount of solar panels there's an
awful lot of roof there um and there is
an opportunity
that we can have to make some kind of uh
of contribution um but i'd also
um liked uh there was a a phrase in
there i didn't quite understand
what is it amended messing please i
didn't quite know what that was
and the other point that i wanted to
come back on was
um you know are we still accepting uh
that where the recommendation
is 25 square meters as a minimum that we
are now
accepting less do we take that as that's
going to be the guiding principle in
future
thank you mr matthews um
be helpful unless you want to show the
solar panels if you could um
oh i see you have done it i think to
show the solar panels
and if you'd like to come back on that
and perhaps mr lee might like to come
back
after you've responded as well i i see
his
now appearing on my screen so i suspect
that means he'd like to speak so miss
matthews please
okay yes so um there may well be
opportunities to provide more solar
panels if
that's what members think is desirable
and necessary in this case um that could
certainly be something that could be
secured by
um condition um
if if the msa members felt like that um
in terms of amended massing um
not quite sure where that five
five four twelve chairman okay
thank you very much bring the um
[Music]
what page is that uh it is page
58 chairman thank you
is that that yes i've got the paragraph
now
yes thank you if you could perhaps
well the um the the massing
the buildings are obviously um
bigger in the in in in that they've now
got pitch roofs on them rather than flat
roof so they're
able to say that the massing has
actually has increased
um um through the addition of the
pictures on top of the
um the buildings and which were
previously
flat roofs okay mr lee you're looking as
though you wish to come in
so i i'll let you come in thank you just
in relation to
uh the most recent point into immunity
space um
the count the site delivers
amenity space differently to how um
you'd normally see with independent
running most akin i would say to shared
many space that you'd find with
flats and developments like that in a
more of a contemporary fill
which though isn't falling it's not
saying though that the community space
isn't acceptable and the reason for the
product or the reason for the removing
of the pd rights isn't because the
as i think was council heard implied in
his first com first question
is not because we're saying the immunity
space isn't acceptable it's because of
the
untraditional style and delivery of the
immunity space that we wouldn't want to
allow
a plethora of outbuildings probably not
maybe we may do but probably wouldn't
want to allow that
willy-nilly for one of a better phrase
across the site as and how
an applicant may feel the future
occupier may feel
but as also as i said arguably they
won't even be able to deliver those
outbuildings anyway so
this isn't saying that we are going to
be accepting less than 25 meters squared
per dwelling in the future and i'm not
quite sure
why the report would come across and
apologize if it does but
to echo what councillor channel the
chairman said at the beginning
and ms matthews members need to be aware
that this application
is solely in relation to reserve matters
matters that have been looked at
at the outline stage such as
access and location etc i have
um you know the principal development
etc have all been looked at and have all
been found satisfactory
um case law is very clear that as
decision makers we can't go back to
revisit those points
so matters have been agreed through the
section 106 or imposed through
conditions outlined stage
have been agreed and we can't be
revisited
and obviously members are all fully
aware that it was relatively recently
reserved matters was before yourselves i
think it was june off the cuff i
remember it was fairly early in life
yeah um and
you know this scheme in relation to many
of the points that have been
you know uh for consideration today is
including the proposed
immunity space how it works and the
functionality of it
were considered by members at that time
and were found to be acceptable
it's a very dangerous situation to
revisit matters that have already been
found acceptable
at subsequent applications so quickly
afterwards and when there were
no new material considerations so i
think to echo what council channel said
earlier
members need to be very focused on the
debate today in relation to the fact
that his reserve matters
and read it very recently in planning
terms an application was
refused solely on design and apart from
the design of the buildings
the application is identical in math in
details matter
and members need to be very conscious of
that today that would just be my advice
thank you chairman
uh thank you mr lee yes i did try and
make that clear i hoped at the beginning
when i said
what's being considered today um there
was a previous refusal and that was on a
single
reason of refusal and that is detailed
into
um two separate arenas um on the report
that's before members tonight
uh thank you councillor miss white
please uh you were next on my list
yeah thank you madam chairman um i'd
just like to say that
i'd like to thank the officers and the
applicants for doing so much work
um with this application i had a big
problem with the design because they
were like
um square boxes and we have had the
working groups we have had
the work put in there and i just like
thank them for actually taking our
comments on board
and trying to improve them as much as we
can i mean i know
um some members still want further
changes but i
personally am really happy that they've
come to us they've taken away the flat
roofs which made them look like square
boxes
um and i think it's a much much better
design as it's already been said
we can't refuse on anything like the
layout or the design or the gardens
because the only
issue we can raise is the design and for
me
as one of the members that raised it um
i think they've done a really good job
and i'd like to thank them and i
actually support this application
um after the changes have been made
thank you very much councilwright now
councillor maze i think you wanted to
but i think your question has been
answered can you confirm
councillor maize uh yes thank you very
much madam chairman it has just been
answered thank you
okay counselor passenger please
i can see you want to speak councillor
bussinger
thank you madam chairman um i would just
like to go back to this
messing really so the problem is there
were flat roofs and that was the
that was the design issue that we didn't
like and now they've put
pointy roofs on them how does that
change the scale
of the building in height how much
higher
are they right um i'll need an officer
to answer that one
um obviously it's gone from it's gone to
ridges and things like that so
i'm sure miss matthews will be able to
advise
yes um through chairman i did put a
little table in the report at
um yes i can't actually see the full
report i can't remember a number of
things being detailed there but yeah
it helped me a few point members in that
direction yes actually if you
want to share the screen with the report
miss bird might be able to
miss bird are you able to share the
screen at this point regarding
do that be helpful i think to help my
assist counsellor bassinger and other
members
yeah i think it's the right one chairman
is matthews that's the one i recall
um yeah i think that's correct
chairman yeah right okay
so yeah so that'd be great so in terms
of the bungalows this was the bungalows
and we've got the um reach heights
there
4.2 meters to 5.9 oh that was previously
so it's now 6
meters to 6.1 yes yes
so and um in terms of the
other buildings
it's massive they um
i don't think i didn't do a um
a comparison with them
so with the care home what's the nine
point four then and the four
fourteen point seven do you chairman so
as you can see here you know the maximum
for the bungalows was 5.4
that's now raised by 0.2 of a meter um
for that for the independent living it's
gone from eight point eight to twelve
point three
which is an increasing uh 3.5 meters
for the care home it's from 9.9 to 14.7
which is increase of 4.8
the medical centers it seems to be quite
a large increase which is from
almost five meters and then in relation
to the community hub it's an increase
from 9.7 to 12.1
which obviously is an increase in 2.4
meters obviously
the medical center whilst being a
relatively large increase is still
lower in height than the community hub
the care home and the independent living
what one thing i'd like to flag up to
members at this time
is that the the principle of
having buildings of a certain number of
stories
was agreed through condition at the
outline stage
so and as discussed at the time of the
last application
and members were fully aware as
explained that that had been agreed and
by
not accepting flat roofs as a point of
principle members were accepting that
there would be pitch roofs on these
buildings
which then meant as the heights of
stories had been agreed that the
buildings would have to
come up to heights such as this so the
fact that they are
buildings of a certain height has been
something in principle that we have
accepted
either through in by the time of the
outline because we accepted that they
would be
buildings of a certain story height and
these are
pitched roof buildings so i know members
may sit here
be a little bit disappointed in reality
the principle of having buildings of
this height
isn't something for consideration today
it's really down to design would be my
advice members
yes and i think if i recall at the last
meeting um members made the point about
what was before in terms of design
didn't fit in with the
more sort of local built form and wanted
something that reflected perhaps uh
something that did uh reflect more and
also the materials
and i believe the materials have also
been addressed now um sort of brig and
wood etc um i'd agree chairman the
higher up members didn't mention that
they would like to see pitched roof so
objecting to the principal pitch roofs
now i think would be a very very
dangerous direction to go down
particularly taking into account the
height of or the principle of having
certain stories of buildings has been
accepted
at outline stage thank you chairman does
that help cancel the passenger
no i don't know i just wanted to get
quite mad excuse me can i
sorry who was that speaking over sorry
mr johnson i just wanted to just on the
back of that
with particular designs comes
constructional
issues as well and when you have pitch
roofs there are
constructional constraints which come
along with that
these are matters that we normally take
into consideration when we're
considering design and scaling those
sorts of matters
so moving from flat roofs to pitch roofs
and giving the building control
standards that they would need to be
built to
are matters to be taken into
consideration thank you
um counselor passenger does that help it
might help perhaps if you see
it sort of helps but you know it doesn't
completely because here we are
talking about design and the only thing
that's changed in the design is there
are pointy
pointy roofs on it we need to know what
what those roofs will look like we need
to know what the cladding will look like
we need to know if that cladding
meets the fire regulations especially in
view of the
very stringent new fire regulations
where cladding is concerned and i know
that is about
tower blocks but i can see that
transferring to the housing market and i
do think that
people that live in these places need to
be protected and we should
be looking at the materials and how
these roofs will look
as as a design issue sorry madam
chairman but the design hasn't changed
at all all we have are taller buildings
with pointy hats on them which
then will cause a demonstrative harm
even more than this
will look in the situation it's in and i
don't think any of that we can say
in principle but we haven't taken any of
those things which are design issues
we haven't discussed them thank you
thank you chairman just a moment please
i think the cladding you might be
referring to is actually as a building
regulations matter i'm sure mr lee might
come in
i think what might be helpful uh miss
matthews if you don't mind if you can
go to your presentation again show what
was
uh before members back in june which
obviously members weren't happy with
show now and do the comparison so show
what was before in june what is now on
the table
for if just the buildings that would be
helpful so bungalow's care home
if you could just do that part of the
presentation again um i think that might
assist uh councillor bassinger and
others right thank you
thank you can i just say up to echo i
think what you implied
i think it's a very dangerous statement
to say that these buildings have just
had pointy roofs put on top of them
these there has been a yes you know a
very detailed and
um deliberate attempt to change
the scheme in the association to the
comments were made by members last time
and
comments made in the pre-application
process and i said miss matthews i think
what you've asked to do is actually
exactly what i was about to do in
perfect to do is to show how
fundamentally different they are and to
take such a blase comment is dangerous
and i just think members need to be very
careful what they're saying in a debate
um furthermore as you said matters such
as
you know whether or not cladding would
be safe etc is not a plan in
consideration
in our legislation or our remit and it's
not something for us to consider tonight
thank you chairman yes so miss matthews
if you could show like you're showing
this is the new design if you can show
the comparator then of the bungalows
what was before
just to assist councillor bassinger now
the member that might think
there hasn't been any design changes
because in my view there's been quite
significant changes so
ms matthews please but if you go through
that part of your presentation again
i know it might take a bit of time but
the buildings show what was before which
members didn't like
and what has now come forward on this
application thank you
so thank you chairman the um
so this is an example of the bungalow
type 3 which is proposed
and um
i haven't got completely comparative
drawings in terms of floor plans and
everything but
these are the illustrations of the
scheme that would previously refuse
which
[Music]
is clearly very different design concept
proportions fenestration pattern um
roof detailing um compared to what is
now proposed which is um
on your screen now one was very
contemporary more and the others want
members wanted more
similar built form to him in burnham and
referred to materials i think at that
time as well
thank you yes go on now that would be
helpful thank you the next set of
buildings
we've got independent living units and
these are proposed so
brick and thailand and timber cladding
and then we've got the um elevations
which were previously refused which is
flat roofs very contemporary um
ugly you know boxes and rectangular
boxes
together and again different different
materials
and then we've got care home again
proposed elevations
and then we've got the refuse elevations
which again
you know very different um
i know design concept and um proportions
and
detailing
and then community center similar change
there is there is an element of flat
roof as part of this building but
um only a single story
on one side
[Music]
and then we've got the refuse elevations
which
um again very different different
materials different
um design concept com
completely and medical center again
um they uh described it as um
like a barn-like it's got some like um
features that you might find on a barn
and with the um
the door barn doors even on on there and
then
again that's an illustration um but
that's the
previously proposed one which is very
very very different um
very modern very contemporary lots of
glass
flat roofs um very contemporary design
features
okay thank you very much so act um
sorry council passenger i do hope that
assisted there because i think you may
see then that
things have changed regarding in in
terms
of the design i've got councillor stamp
and council of lagging wishing to ask
questions or speak so counsel the stamp
please
yes thank you madam chair um just a
couple of things if i'm allowed to come
back especially
after what mr lee said and also
confirmation of the actual planning
approval
it says in uh page 48 the outline
application was proved on the 13th of
september
i thought it was approved in january
2019
chairman i just would like confirmation
to that because
not quite that good um
the decision would be when that would be
when the decision actually would have
been issued
planning approval was approved in
january 2019 wasn't it at the full
council meeting
no that's not until the decision notices
issued so
this is very misleading mr lee because i
remember it actually
your maybe is going to say to me don't
pull your face up because you always
screw it up when you're talking to
can we stop that sort of you know
chucking things at each other can we
just
get on with the meeting now um just come
just make it clear i believe it was to
do with part of the legal agreement i've
seemed to recall something about this
but i could be wrong
it's it's standard it's no different to
us members will know
the south morgan relief road application
that came back two years later that
legally and this is the point it's
legally a decision is when the decision
notice goes out
so it's not planned semantics that's
just to point the law thank you
thank you does that help counsellor
stamp
it does but if you let me speak before
everybody interrupts me all the time
thank you well i'm just trying to assist
to see if it helps
please continue right
with cancer mr stamp please uh thank you
thank you mr lee i think it's important
that all the residents know because a
lot of people thought it was was
approved in january
so clarity is absolutely helpful to
everybody and also other members
that weren't actually elected as
district councillors at the time
and also um can i see a picture
please of the um what i call the asda
building
which is the where the shops are have we
got that please that members can see
you know where all the shops are and the
accommodation at the top for people who
are the workers to live in can we see
that please members
are the shops are that south of the site
isn't it
yes it it's it's actually near the main
road but i just like
to see that we that's it that's it
well i remember saying at the time in
these discussions chairman
and other people who attended these
meetings i think that is horrendous
i still think it's horrendous but i also
do have sympathy with the
developer who's trying to appease um
30 councillors who have different
visions on what it's going to look like
the scale balkan mass is is awful
and so is the care home i don't know
what members want to do about it
but i certainly don't like it the
bungalows are great and the other
buildings that are trying to incorporate
what burnham has
in its town is fine i just just do not
like i don't know if the developers can
suggest something
but it's just too big it's just too much
too much bulk and scale
and mass and that's all i want to say
because otherwise
i'm sure you'll stop me madam chair
thank you i won't stop you cancel the
stamp i always try to be fair to
remember can we just see what was on the
um
previous what was the bitty previously
regarding the mixed use
is that possible do we have that through
chairman that that
part of the scheme hasn't changed it's
exactly the same as it was in part the
last reserve matters
right okay so that that hopefully might
um help
counselor stamp as well um councillor
lagan you wanted to comment
can i comment supplementary yes you can
come back i'll let councillor heard so
supplementary yes
yeah i know it's exactly the same it
hasn't changed my point is
it wasn't addressed it hasn't been
changed and the other thing is the care
home
you didn't put the picture up of the
care home that is that is absolutely
huge and i think members should have a
look at that as well thank you
miss matthews the care home please
what was before and what's now
yeah three chairmen so the care home
their home that was previously refused
and um that's what's currently proposed
now okay yeah thank you very much thank
you
it is a big it is a big building it was
it was a big building
um 70 70 bedrooms it is
a substantial building but has been um
broken up into elements and
i know because of its shape as well it
won't be
and appear as such a big building as if
it was
um designed differently also
chairman members need to remember that
layout was a consideration at outline
stage so the
acceptance of this level of built form
in a layout so covering that land of
that area of landmass was agreed at
outline stage
and as i said conditions are imposed
restricting
story heights so the principle of having
buildings of a certain height
and definitely a certain level of area
and
agglomeration in bulk form was accepted
at outline stage so
whether members like this or not this is
that is not a matter to be
revisiting tonight because that has been
just
been accepted by the council it would be
unbelievably dangerous to look to review
that now
thank you thank you very much councillor
lagan
please i believe that's
like oh right you're there good thank
you i did have connectivity earlier on
but i've put another 50p in the meter so
um wind generated electricity of course
um
first of all um i just want to say thank
you to councillor stamp because
getting some clarification of when the
the outline of planning commission
uh was was passed does actually give
some clarity
and i know matt we can't turn back that
the past and
uh nor would we but i'm sure that the
decisions would have been different
but they're not um so we have to deal
with what's in front of as you say
i agree uh surprisingly with the
councillor white
i've got some prepared notes here and
that i i
agree that the developers have been
incredibly collaborative
in the way that they've revisited the
design and the bungalows
i think are exceptional i think they
look so much better
and certainly are in appearance where i
have a problem here
um is that the larger buildings they
still would like a cross between a
shopping center in colchester
and the problem i have with
illustrations is that you know
we've got we've got three cars parked
there and three loved up couples walking
around the place so illustrations are
rather dangerous
um and danger as the member is being
part of the role
so that description has come out a lot
and i i get
the the advice and accept the advice
that mr lee says
but it is a subjective aspect as an
individual member
to say that yes some of this development
is absolutely exceptional
um albeit we have to put our tongues
back in our heads on some of it
but the other areas of it that there
could still be some work to be done
so it doesn't sit well with with myself
just the balkan skull
and the appearance of those larger
buildings thank you madam chairman thank
you members and thank you mr lee
thank you very much well i can see um no
other members wishing to speak
actually on on this debate but you know
can i just say i haven't finished yet
please thanks
um i was just going to say i believe
councillor did moot about
solar panels um was that another member
wishing to say something i think
councillor heard maybe
uh you did make it clear i thought that
he perhaps thought solar panels
um we ought to get as much solar panels
as possible can i ask you trying to talk
over me please
me it's anne i i have been trying to get
through oh right okay
right councillor hull oh lovely thank
you
i'd like to again uh say how you know it
has been changed to
the planning has been changed and thank
you very much to all those involved in
it
solar panels would be a really good idea
in my my idea
um the bridal way around the outside
they said it wasn't going to come in
until the 106
um is it 106 came through have you got
any idea because
in burnham we have no right away and
that
could be another 10 years on really
has they got any ideas um through
chairman the bridal idea dealt with
through the section 106 and
there are uh requirements of if of when
it needs to be imposed but that's not
something
for consideration today because this is
the reserve matters
i i can remember that actually coming up
in the days when the outline was first
heard and i believe it was councillor
acevedo at that time
raised their bridal way and i can
remember that as mr lee then said
it is already been doubt it's not a
matter for tonight but it is
under the the one i believe i haven't
obviously seen all the detail of the 106
on the schedules necessarily behind but
mr lee's um informed that it is
regarding part of the 106 so i hope that
satisfies
that element i hope so yes thank you
yeah and the other matches um council
hull um has raised does any
other officer want to come in on
anything that council hell's raised
if i can be um help i've got the 106
here and it's
lovely thank you i think that might help
the bridal way
um needs to be agreed
prior to the occupation of the 80th open
market dwelling
right does that help cancer hull i think
that's answered the question
it's on the 106 that was quite a long
way did that
could you say that again it's got on the
80th dwelling did they say oh
yeah didn't quite hit yeah 80. yeah
so unless unless everything's finished
there's no bridleway
well i think there's more than 80
drawings yeah it's three hm and there's
a lot more than eighty twelve yeah
um how section 106's work is that it's
very rare for
things that quite have a financial
contribution to be required
prior to first occupation because there
needs to be almost a
sort of a free flow of the process so
it's um around about
that sort of figure trigger point is
quite common in planning applications
um but yeah but to be honest even if you
don't like that members i'm afraid you
know that has been agreed with the time
for revisiting tonight
thank you okay does that help counselor
i think that's clear it helps
it's not a matter of tonight but i hope
that gives you the information
okay thank you um before i go back to
the solar panel yesterday i heard
councillor heard
mentioning earlier and i think he might
want to say something more on that
um uh i've got councillor morris wishing
to speak and then i
i can't see many more so after that
we'll go back to council heard so
councillor morris
chairman just before councilman just
advised councillor swain i think he's
also been trying to speak
i couldn't say anything about council
swain has he put a hand up i haven't
even seen a hand up
yeah okay okay i can't see council swain
at all on mine so
do do apologise
please please counselor and speak
i'll let councillor swain speak first
because
he gets the bed earlier than me
councillor swain
um i'm sorry i couldn't see you on my
chat but i understand from
uh mrs bird that you wish to speak
councillor yes yes thank you chairman
i've been having some trouble with the
chat and so on
um i agree that um having been involved
in those pre-application sessions that
the um
that considerable changes have been made
in improving
the designs so i don't have a
too much of a problem on that score what
i do want to raise is an aspect which i
haven't seen addressed unless it was at
a very early stage
and that is the question of the
openness of this site and the fact that
the retail
health and leisure facilities will
inevitably bring in a lot of people from
outside
to to use them and this is an aspect of
traffic
and safety for vulnerable residents
which i
haven't seen addressed at all um this
site is going to
attract people to come for those
facilities
from outside places in burnham and say
al thorne
um to to use them and this will
generate additional traffic which
doesn't seem to have been catered for
thank you thank you i'll let the officer
come back but i don't believe that's an
element for discussion tonight
councillor swain tonight really is all
about
uh the relevant pla material planning
considerations to do with the considered
details
of scale appearance and landscaping um
that matter i don't believe about um i
think you're talking about vehicular
movements and everything
um you know people coming to the site mr
chairman this would come under
landscaping in a sense because it's
the availability of the land to provide
adequate parking
the parking was described in the report
mr lee please i think there's the issues
here council swain's talking about
parking but also the visitors arriving
at the site not just those who
live on the site are you chairman the
scheme is post compliant when it comes
to car parking and obviously that
relates to
wider than just or you know these uses
have
if anything would need less car parking
requirements here because of the
fact that in theory majority of people
would be on site but there is an
acceptance that
there is car parking provision for
people externally
but the main point is that this was
accepted and actually was a point of
discussion at the time of the outline
and this is a matter of highways and the
principle of traveling through those
sites remembering the access
which is include parking or not parking
principle but you know
roads etc through a site you know
footpaths cycle path etc is access and
that was agreed to outline so this
matter was a matter for outline that's
why it's not included in this
reserve matters application it hasn't
already been accepted that there will be
custom customers and users from outside
the site coming on
but they'll also be visitors to the the
property so in theory there's no real
difference in respect of that
so yeah that is something that we have
looked at already although there was
condition number 10 mr lee which does
make it clear about the car parking and
prior to the occupation of dwellings
hereby permitted um it does make it
quite clear about the hard surfacing
required and the bay is being marked out
and also that should remain in
perpetuity
so that's covered i think it's to ensure
the on-street parking of vehicles in
to ensure um so the on-street parking of
vehicles in adjoining street does not
occur in the interests
so there is an element of the car
parking just ensuring about getting it
surfaced um
um and everything so councillor morris
thank you councillor swain does that
answer
i believe it does i think the officers
answered that and made that clear
i was afraid mr lee would say that yes
thank you uh okay
councillor morris please thank you madam
chair
um you'll have to excuse me i've still
got my old plates on i've not been a uh
counsellor for that long
um i've just i wanted just to address
the uh the elephant in the room as it
was
i mean i believe that last time this
application came before us
we've obviously knocked it back you know
because of the flat roof and the pitch
roof and stuff like that
um from what mr lee has said uh am i to
understand that
uh because this this application
is quite unpopular from from what i can
see
my predisposition would be to refuse
this
on ecology grounds on environmental
grounds basically because
you know it's just not needed too big
massive
it's not what people want to see as they
go into
the lovely town of burnham um now if
we've refused this previously
we can't and we can't revisit any other
um
refusal reasons were we not sort of like
steered into this
with some members maybe knowing full
well that they could
um go away give it a little bit of a
wiggle change
the flat roofs to pitch moves and then
bring it back
and now we apparently can't be
um bringing up that the place will look
terrible is is that my understanding is
that the way it is now
well i'll let officers come back but the
outlying application has established the
principle of development for want of a
better word on this site
members when they considered the
application in june there was a sole
reason of refusal
many issues were debated and in fact
some have been raised again tonight and
in fact some are still going back to the
outline applicant state
application stage so the principle on
development on this site for this
development if you like has been given
these are the reserved matters and i
must point out again the only items
that are to be considered under this
application was the scale appearance
landscaping and i will remind once again
that members the sole reason of refusal
on the application was the design as
clearly pointed out
in two areas the reason for refusal is
detailed in two areas on your order
paper
but uh miss matthews would you like come
back to answer councillor morris's
point about that or mr lee
i think i think you've answered it very
well
and i don't think i've got anything else
to add thank you
please it looks like mr lee might have
something to say i think that's dude
chairman i think you did answer it
except you well but just for clarity
um to be honest i think i had very
similar conversations at the time of the
last application and a lot of the points
that
council most raised such as ecology
which should deal with the conditions on
through the outline
but i think he's getting at the point of
loss of a field per se
the fact that people don't want to see
this they coming to burnham
they really go to the heart of the
principle of the application
rather than being for reserve matters so
the council was accepted by grant and
outline permission that
x amount of properties will be built
there that will include
uh certain other forms of development
there will be hard standing through
access
we've all as i said we accepted the or
we had for consideration accepted the
layout so we had the bulk of the
building so all of that was looked at
outline
so when it came to the last application
which was refused
just like with this there were actually
very few points one of a better word
that members really are actually looking
at because
a lot of them have been accepted by the
council and members can members go
officers come officers go but the
council is consistent
and the council is the decision maker
whether it's delegated or
committee it's always the council's
decision maker and i know you think i'm
playing semantics with word counselors i
can tell by your face but
that's what the law is unfortunately and
that's
that is where we are so the points you
raised i would actually say
are not it's we can't look at them now
because that was outlined not because we
didn't
look at them last time as the reserve
matters they'd already the
the hul the horse said he bolted to use
a quotalism thank you chairman
thank you very much hope that answers it
council morris i'll supplement you allow
you one supplementary
supplementary supplement or whatever it
is please um thank you uh mr lee
um there's a famous quote uh saying
about the law being
it's not my one someone else's um some
of the
worst things in in in history have been
legal
but um just going back to it i think
that i feel a little bit
i feel a little bit tucked up by uh this
whole thing and i'm sure the
residents of burnham will too um but
we're learning
thank you very much um counselor stan uh
council heard i haven't forgotten you
uh councillor stamp you wanted to come
back as you are a burnham member
i will of course allow you to come back
thank you can i just say that um
it really is important because don't
forget this decision was made before we
were elected
and i think we raised at the june
meeting mr lee didn't we that we were
very concerned
and because we didn't really we was
unsure what we could talk about and what
we couldn't because like what you've
just explained through you chairman
and that those decisions was already
made but when you're newly elected
it's really important you get the
history in the background
and we through you chairman we keep
being told we're not experienced but we
also keep getting shut down when we try
to get the experience and try to get the
knowledge at these meetings
and i think it's really important that
everybody
understands this process and and i want
to say one more thing please
mr lee always says at planning meetings
we have to be careful about setting a
dangerous precedent
and what um councillor heard said about
the immune
immunity space whether it's being
changed to suit this application
i think is irrelevant and i think it is
important we have to be careful
we are not changing something just to
suit this application
and yes i know you're gonna we can't
talk about it in that much detail
but it is important and i am the ward
member and i thank you for letting me
speak
because i get a post bag full of
complaints about this application
so thank you chairman uh thank you
councillor stamp i think what mr lee is
just trying to point out to help and
um obviously um happened to me myself
you come in at a certain
time on a council and what's gone before
um but decisions have been made and
the the fact of the matter is there is
the principle of development on here i
was in that debate i'm not going to say
any more about that but i think he's
just trying to point out to members
what's important tonight to bear in mind
what this application is about
and what the reason was for refusal
which was one singular issue the reports
made that quite clear and miss matthews
and mr lee
i think are just trying to guide members
to make them clear what the decision
tonight should be based on
now mr councillor passenger i'm going to
be very lenient here but i am after this
going to move on to councillor heard
um because i know he mentioned um solar
panels i have seen something on the chat
which shouldn't have been really on the
chat but because of that i will let him
come in but
councillor passenger just i'll let you
come back once more supplementary
thank you madam sherman and just a
question to mr lee really i mean
as far as yeah through the chair sorry
sorry um as far as i gathered the the
the only thing we can really talk
about is the design of these bungalows
and
yes i can see and you're you are right
it isn't just a pointy ruse
the design has changed but if we could
look at those
designs again the first designs although
they weren't fitting in with the area
and we felt that they were not the right
design
the second design which looked to me
just like a box
with a pointy roof on it so there was my
comment i
i don't see how we have a better design
we have
an other design i'm not sure that that's
a design that we would want to see
either really so maybe something more
inhibitive something you know
certainly with a pointy roof but maybe
something that looks aesthetically
a little better than that i'm not sure
the design has improved
mr lee through the chair the council
passenger did ask if you could be asked
just to and i'm i think i know what you
might say but
perhaps if you could i'd be grateful
thank you chairman um you probably know
i'm going to say designs
subjective matter um yeah i thought you
might think
i think to be honest you know
unfortunately development management is
not about blue sky thinking it's about
seeing if
there is harm and it's to such a degree
as it wants a reason for refusal
um i don't know of pretty much any
scheme that you wouldn't look at and
think that it could be slightly improved
so
it's not a case of just saying we can
improve the scheme we have to be able to
show there's
much more harm my big concern is that
the reality is that the layout of the
which shows the floor area of the
buildings has been accepted
um the scale in relation while its
consideration has been restricted or
limited through condition but has
guaranteed certain level of
built form on the site and i do think
there is only
certain amount of wiggle room for one of
the better phrase within that
and i members have to be very conscious
of that you know the layout so
as you're looking at really how they'll
fit on the floor is accepted so
it does make it very hard for us and i
do think members have to be conscious
and i can understand members b situation
you know they we all know that we don't
necessarily always like a previous
recommendation
or a previous decision from the council
and obviously on a scheme such as this
where
it was determined before lots of members
were in place
um and it may or may not be popular
which is not really planning to sit
material consideration um does make it
hard for members and
as i you know to appoint council stamps
you know
point i'm always happy to discuss
planning with members if they do have
any queries and over the
years i've spoken to lots of members and
so if you do have queries before a
committee about points obviously please
come to me or
mr johnson on the case office we are
happy to discuss that but unfortunate
applications such as where
the applicant actually did apply for
more reserve matters than you
at the time of the outline you'd
normally find we have very limited
points of discussion
and for determination tonight and it's
it
i know and i can't understand members
frustration but that is where we are
where we are unfortunately
thank you chairman thank you very much
through youtube just quickly come back
just one
thing but again just just to reiterate
that the design we have is just an
alternative design
it isn't necessarily a better design and
there is a change in scale
so the designing effectively you know is
up for discussion again i believe
because as i say we
we ask for an alternative they haven't
um altered
the shopping area that's exactly the
same apparently
so these bungalows have they've gone
from one look to something completely
different
that doesn't necessarily mean that we
have to accept that surely there is a
change of scale they have a
amassing something or other the roofs
and
and the design itself has gone from
something which is modern to something
which is sort of
box standard um do we have to accept
that
well i think i'm not sure mr well
obviously mr lee does want to come back
i think
um on the order papers everything clear
he's mentioned the subjective
and you can see by the officer's
viewpoint the world considered report i
would say it's a thorough report
and the conclusion of it i think drew it
all together very swiftly and clearly
and uh in fact officers views it does
not result in demonstrable harm and that
it does meet
the policies and other matters but mr
lee i will let you come back
and i am moving on to council ahead you
have once again you've covered it
excellently i've not really got anything
to say you know
you know it's recorded vote please
is that seconded
in that case please uh councillor heard
i'm coming back to you purely because i
did see a chat
you did use the chat when really um it
would be better for you to spoken
through the debate
but i think it might be centering around
the issue of the solar panels you raised
and i think mrs um sorry miss matthews
mrs matthews i do apologize
um that didn't indicate if members so
wish he
said that could be done by condition i
think that was said
very early on in the debate is that what
the issue is councillor heard please
yes uh thank you chairman uh may i say
that uh i think
the the first refused design uh
was quite right to be refused i
i think that there certainly is an
improvement it i wouldn't say it was my
favorite but
there certainly is an improvement in the
new design
i think that we are talking about
appearance and scale
uh it's clear that if we ask for pitched
grooves the scale will increase
um however as far as the appearance goes
um i think we have now got
a lot of roof space now i'm not
an expert in solar panels but i do know
uh that a six panel system uh will
pay for itself after 10 years
so it should be an average saving of
about 385 pounds
per year so my my uh proposal is
that there should be more than a nod to
renewables
if we are to have this uh and i would
like to see an increase
in solar panels so that there should be
a six-panel system
uh for uh each individual
premises right is that
sec that's a proposal for you chairman
can i just
quickly yeah i'm going to say because i
don't i'm i'm not technical on solar
panels and i think um
miss matthews indicated perhaps it could
be done if some members wish by
condition but yes please come back
we can impose a condition in relation to
additional
additional
uh solar panels to be required or you
know a scheme to be detailed
um i would feel uncomfortable with
putting on a definitive statement
such as that without having any level of
information because if for some reason
that's not possible you would actually
put on a condition that would
floor the whole permission which is
obviously unreasonable so
um i can quite happily
suggest members that officers could
accept a condition imposed
which will if members are happy get the
exact word dean agreed with with the
chair
but if you can delegate okay thank you
can we just be clear is that would that
be seconded i think what we're saying is
uh an additional condition so condition
21 to cover
the solar panels increase solar panel
aspect
i would like to send it i'd second that
that's that seconded
is that what you mean mr lee so we'd
have an additional condition a separate
condition
21.
mr lee yes sorry three champion yes
that's correct so they've been
right can we just get that out of the
way then members uh councillor
is proposing that should this be
approved there would be an additional
condition 21 and that's been seconded
now um councillor morris has asked for a
recorded vote
so i suppose i do have to go through
that just to have an additional 21. i
would rather hope that could be done by
a cent i think councillor morris's main
recorded vote was on the
actual decision um but i think perhaps
then
i will say take a recorded vote as it
was requested we'll have to on that term
that extra condition so miss bird please
i think we'll do it
um through uh please you
can we have at the details taken so this
members
is to agree the additional condition
21 about solar panels and then i'll have
to that would then help us move the
substantive
wreck because i've moved the
recommendation as was so
um and it was seconded so therefore can
we do that please on this
so additional one about the solar panels
thank you should it be
approved of course obviously thank you
thank you chairman and members uh
if you could just indicate when i call
your name out uh if you're fought
against or abstaining please
starting with councillor bamford this is
on the 21 the extra condition solar
panels thank you
amendments
[Music]
thank you councillor brian bill oh
councillor bell for
that's mrs chandler well i'm staying
because i'm in the chair
and i move the recommendation counselor
edwards
for you councillors fleming
for councillor heard
four thank you councillor helm
four
four counselor jarvis
oh he wasn't sorry no he was here was he
no no uh counselor keith's captain
or please tara thank you councillor
morris
councillor maize sorry apologies
it's okay four thank you councillor
morley
councilman right not here apologies
i do sorry about that chairman sorry uh
councillor morris
bort thank you very much councillor none
four please charlie thank you
is here oh
council jarvis are you there
he's got connection issues apparently
he's got connection problems oh
thank you very much thank you for that
councillor siddal thank you
sorry tara that's okay a councillor
stamp
oh thank you councillor stilts
for thank you swain
for council mrs thompson
or council miss white
or chairman the result of that is
21-4 nobody against and one abstention
thank you very much i'm now going to
move on then to the
recommendation um i moved it to start
the debate off
so it is uh the planning application
land i won't give the number out
land north west of to malden road
burnham on crouch be approved subject to
the conditions in section 8
of the report but i did point out um on
the members update that the revisions to
which miss matthews agreed was correct
the rulings to two four and five
additional condition number 20
and now we've got additional condition
number 21
um which we've just voted on and that
recommendation was seconded by
councillor bamford
to get the debate going we've now had
the debate and council of morris has
requested a recorded vote on this
members
and um it was seconded so therefore we
will have the recorded vote
and i would point out uh what the
officers have um
advised tonight and bearing in mind uh
the single issue
um of the refusal of the last
application so councillor spurred please
if i may can i ask you please to take a
roll call which will become the recorded
vote
uh detailed in the minutes thank you
thank you chairman uh members so as
before if you could just indicate four
against or abstain please starting with
castle bamford
four thank you councillor bussinger
against you councillor spiel
for brian bill
four councillor belle what are the
heavy heart for that's the mrs chennai
i love staying because i was in the
chair i'm in the chair
councillor edwards for
you council mrs fleming for
cancer heard four thank you
councillor helm for
the council of health for
uh chairman councillor jarvis obviously
didn't wasn't able to vote on the first
one so um
tara but i think i'll be obliged to
abstain because i was
out for two or three minutes apologies
that's no problem thank you for advising
and counsellor lagan against please tara
thank you councillor mays against
councillor morris
against thank you councillor none
well given the outline and the improved
design i feel no alternative but four
thank you counselor seancey
thank you council siddal against
thank you cancer stamp against
the stilts abstains that cara
that's the swain before
thank you mrs thompson
oh that's the miss white
four tara chairman the result of that is
14 4 6 against and two abstentions
thank you thank you very much therefore
that application members has been
approved
with 21 conditions um three of which
were revised as per the
members update so thank you very much
that's an approval
um and we've agreed that and the
recorded vote of course will be shown in
the minutes
therefore i move on to gender item
number seven business by reason of
special circumstances considered by the
chairman to be urgent
i can inform members i do have none and
therefore i move members to gender item
number eight
uh members i sincerely thank you for
your uh contributions this after uh this
evening rather
i now draw this special uh this meeting
to a close
at and by my computer it says 1939
and as the meeting is now closed members
can i please just politely advise you
not to enter any further discussion
um on this forum and to please leave the
meeting promptly
thank you very much indeed and can i
thank all the officers
uh for your help tonight and thank you
uh miss bird especially
um for as usual uh keeping me online
and getting all the votes recorded thank
you very much indeed everyone the
meeting is now closed
thank you